also interesting yesterday cnn was able
to get an interview
with president zielenski in his bunker
he's been in a bunker for some period of
time and
occasionally exiting the bunker uh to uh
record videos and do different things
that we have seen cnn's matthew chan
spoke with zolensky in the bunker about
what's going on with negotiations and
other things and it is incredible to see
you sent your delegation to meet the
russians for talks
did anything substantial come out of
that is there any hope
as the world watches for diplomacy they
decided they decided
uh
to begin to speak about this situation
and i want it i i really wanted and i
asked them so you have to speak first of
all you everybody has to
stop
stop fighting and to go to that point
from where
it it was beginning yes it began five
today six six days ago yes i think
there are principal things you can do it
and that is very important moment if you
do this and if those side is ready it
means that they are ready for the piece
the the level of
i've never been like a big zelinski fan
or anything like it but
the level of poise
that
he is exhibiting
from a bunker
separated from his family
as bombs are dropping
shelling is happening all over the
country
it is just incredible if they don't
ready it means that you're
just you know
just
um
wasting time do you think you're wasting
your time or do you think they're ready
we'll see
just uh i i mean it is it is
unbelievable what uh is taking place
right now
and um the question around the so-called
negotiations is an important question
we sort of just very casually talked
about well what is it russia would want
in such negotiations i imagine russia
would want to officially kind of see
ukraine give up on crimea
and probably give up on the donetsk and
luhansk regions that's that that's
probably something russia would want is
that something ukraine would be willing
to give it's hard to imagine
on the other hand i would imagine that
ukraine would want
russia to accept that if ukraine joins
nato or if ukraine joins the eu
it would not be opposed by russia or
seen as a sign of aggression or as a
justification for aggression by russia
and it's very hard to imagine that
that's something that russia would
accept as well so they talk about
negotiations
it's in a practical sense
very difficult to imagine
what sort of agreement there could be
that would be satisfactory to both sides
but that's why there's such a thing as
professional diplomacy and professional
negotiators we will continue seeing that
there's sort of the two tracks there's
the we are looking at doing some
negotiation on the border with belarus
and there's
at some point putin's going to make his
play for kiev and that could be at any
time and it's not obvious that ukrainian
forces and volunteers are going to be
able to repel the russian forces so the
next 24-48 hours could be key uh we're
going to take a quick break the clips
from that zelensky interview
which is very much worth watching will
be on our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that i have ever made coffee i've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor i really enjoy cometier they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometeer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video